[Music]
for me the journey I'm continually
trying to make is though there's a macro
journey of how can how can the
unenlightened man become enlightened and
then how do i moment-to-moment when i'm
when i reengaged if i want this i want
these people to approve me i want that
happen how do i get back you know if i'm
startled oh so suddenly fearful or
suddenly full of desire how do i
transition back to it so I'm continually
dealing with that voice yeah well it's
the hero's journey and there's something
about your innate humanity and and and
your willingness to be vulnerable in the
storytelling matched with like this
facility from language that you have
that makes it very compelling and then
you'll surprisingly kind of zing people
every once in a while with you know a
paragraph about like here's how you can
do this too but it's done in such a way
where you don't really feel like you're
being preached to in any way because
you're caught up in the storytelling
itself and thank you in the humanity of
it because I don't like being told what
to do I've never liked it who does and
yet there is a whole massive industry
built around these books that are
telling people what to do and people
love reading them and buying them I wish
but I question whether they're effective
I think I think people read these books
a very small percentage of them take
that wisdom and put it into action but I
think a lot of people just feel good
about buying them and maybe feel a
little bit better about reading them and
and then it becomes this sort of placebo
that you might be right except acebos
can be sometimes correct yeah I mean but
like you see you've made a transition in
your life and it's [ __ ] hard isn't it
to go right I'm not gonna be I'm going
to be fit I am going to could put myself
through physical trauma or stress yeah
and so when somebody comes to you and
says Russell tell me how you know you
did this or how do I go from here to
there and and what they want is a
distilled you know six point plan that
they can execute on and life doesn't
work that way and it's through the story
telling humanity that we can connect
with something that can live within us
that has staying power that resonates
that we will remember a year or five or
ten years later hmm yeah I think yes no
I agree with that I believe that but how
to frame it again within the 12 steps
which is how I I you know again lucky is
robust I feel like it works but that if
I'm if I surrender okay that's the first
thing if I go all right I do want to
change I do not want to have this body I
didn't want to have this job I didn't
wanna have these feelings about my
partner I want to feel like I'm an
inadequate father you know once I
recognize once I come to that point of
I've got a problem in my life son
manageable then am I ready just come to
believe that I can be restored to sanity
that is possible I like the optimism at
the program that the program assumes
that it is possible to be happy not like
it's not a some sort prata stand we are
born to suffer suffering this good work
hard flajolet you know because I feel
that you know that I can see how that
idea enters because the death of self
the death of the individual the
flagellation the mortification of the
flesh the loss of the individual does
sound a lot like you know tear yourself
apart but I like the Bliss of Hinduism I
like the Bliss of the vader's I like the
love the voluptuousness the senses I
don't want to become passionless I don't
think I don't you know when I meet like
you know you meet in life people
sometimes I like the mischievous black
dudes that are on your wall back in your
house you know why because when they
move or that or the the self-proclaimed
enlightened person that just hugs you a
little bit too long a bit too much
daring and yes more to this than staring
and hacking and hacking are part of it
you can wake the Reaper nah she has to
take it out into the world yeah and
actually [ __ ] with it that's what's
good about that particular book is the
way that he's saying oh my god I've been
preparing for this my whole life now I'm
on this train I'm not used people
[ __ ] stink yeah guys I have to remind
myself amateur come on this is it if you
can't work on a train how you gonna work
it on the next plane but like he's
saying you know I have there months if
these people have got a bought birth and
a death but they've LeSabre
me likey how did that these principles
are challenged in the material world
that's why I think we need that
fundamental spiritual belief that this
we need to somehow have the faith to
have the commitment this is not real
this is not real and you can see how
people you know how that became the kind
of illness of Kirk reduce secularized
critics Christian cultures all right
your heaven the afterlife so that the
billionaires can get on with being
really just scuttle about in the rubble
no no no is to that someone said to me
in like a one of them like I met with a
group in New Orleans and this man went
to me like he was off - he was such a
romantic fellow so beer didn't stained
shirt and some sort of naval looking hat
and heavy and leathery and he went to me
lady was off to help the homeless and we
were in New Orleans so there was no
shortage and he goes goes yeah the
material world this he says this is this
is just crumbs don't sell for crumbs I
want to be at the banquet to recognize
that anything that occurs within this
limited bandwidth whether it's of
Lamborghinis or limitless orgies it's
nothing it's taking place on that on a
pinhead you know but they don't have
access to some kaleidoscopic experience
but does take discipline the Maya your
bloody thing it's gorgeous isn't it it
is gorgeous a lunatic eating you know
delicious tasting lie I I agree with you
with the optimism of the stuffs but I
also appreciate the matter-of-fact
nature of them it's like you know the
the you will have a spiritual awakening
as a result of these steps not like you
might or you know it's possible but like
just do these things and you will have
this transformation and it doesn't
matter how you feel about it or how much
you're questioning it and the expansion
occurs because look recovery is littered
with people that coming you came in as
an atheist and now you're this like you
know you're ready to start your own
religion basically Stein the occult the
acolytes are you know everywhere at this
point no I just need to get the right
kind of blanket work on that Stan yeah
I'm long cuddle and this is that this is
very good for your ego I would imagine
oh yeah go for the irony yeah but you
feel good on the vegan
I feel good on yeah I've been doing the
BJJ I want to say this to you like yeah
I do the BJJ I love him but when I like
um I love it and I'm not good at it you
know I'm learning I'm no I don't tell
myself negative things little Russell
needs encouragement and love I'm
learning I'm learning um but like today
when I like my wife was putting a new
car seat in the car was the one that's
in there no no no it's not comfortable
know of that two-year-old she's got
she's got some specific taste I thought
I'm gonna say to each rolls how
sometimes how detached I feel from my
buddy my wife he's active she's of the
earth she knows how to be she knows how
to do things thank [ __ ]
it was unlike some gaseous little poet
just floating around commentating you
know where she picks up that car seat
she gets it if you leave me to put a car
seat in top the top tether strap into
the buckle loop I looked it but that's
not how you're wired
you know she grounds you but you can you
know show the vision you know exactly
like you need bow for that right yeah we
know you met you met Julie you can see
there's a similar kind of like yin-yang
dynamic yeah well is it with you guys
I mean I'm much more grounded in
practical and rational and she you know
she's you know an ethereal being right
you know and she allows me to expand my
my not only my perspective but my sense
of what's possible she'll say why don't
you look at it from this perspective and
something I never would have thought of
and a sense of belief like a support and
a belief in a different reality that she
held for us we've been together for a
very long time yeah we've gone through a
lot and when we met we were living
completely different lives but she held
this vision that I could not have seen
myself so you and you and you I think
you I would imagine I'm projecting
completely but that you fulfill that
role in your own relationship yes same
actually I mean in the sense of vision
as in imagining and dreaming new spaces
yes but it was my wife we met when like
inner-self 11 12 years ago and she knew
that we were meant to be together and I
knew I had to try and set world records
for promiscuity
[Laughter]
how did you how did you overcome that
like did you just acquiesce overtime or
what was that process like for you
actually wasn't the promiscuity
ultimately that was problematic but it
was more difficult co-dependent
relationships with inappropriate
partners like in my case just people
that I wasn't like I was very attracted
to well i after a few relationships like
that like after sort of exiting one i
felt like was too jimmy a mentor said i
like ligo's you can't keep doing that
next time you see the sign pointing in
the direction of their glamorous amazing
relationship maybe don't go that way
it's so hard though oh yeah I mean it's
so very alluring the flesh is alluring
and like in it that you know they don't
good we are physical people it's nothing
wrong with her you know unto Caesar what
is Caesar's and all that there's nothing
wrong with the bodies in the world and
but you'd knock down that door enough
time I mean you know you know what that
avails you yeah and when I reconnected
with my wife I felt like oh my god I've
been using totally the wrong metric was
it what do you mean reconnected you had
known her previous yeah we known each
other for 11 years we went out when I
was about in my early thirties and she
was like 20 maybe she was even 19 but
that sounds well but anyway like so then
I was went off to pursue the record and
then like and you know when we got back
like we went on sort of one day and on
the first day is that also you and she's
like you know I'm ready to be a parent
yeah me too and that was you know like
from then on we sort of took it's
relatively slowly still but I think
that's only four years ago and we're
married and we've got two children and
I'm like I'm at peace I know like the
realness of it the earth Ness of it I'm
no longer looking to externally acquire
happiness so to what do you attribute
that shift the program the program the
bit Billy because I've known that that
could have happened at any point you
know it's no no for 10 years by us
wasn't ready to see that I wasn't ready
to let go of the belief that no no I've
you know I want to live this kind of
life on
be this kind of person and it's odd
actually because there is a real
superficiality to that sort of romantic
and expressive and abundant love in that
when those relationship ended I was
quite abled for some well okay because
it was something about it there was a
construct it was taking place in my
consciousness primarily this
relationship was very very very deep
very oft and real like this is a person
that I wouldn't want to be without so
and so I'd not surrendered to that
before yeah
and for years now yeah yeah it's good
it's a relief it's nice to think that
there is nothing like I do it's nice to
have practices I suppose you know as far
as the institution of marriage and
coupling and stuff
I suppose it works in that it's
beautiful to feel you know that idea of
like they're here I am here
that's seeing I but my little daughter
says I sit in my seat I sit in my seat
I'm here I'm looking over there for
something else there isn't some other
new magical thing no other agenda being
present and in it but also with enough
awareness and personal development to
understand that you know you're not
looking to this partner to complete you
and that's your own personal journey
that's your connection with your higher
power and your your you know spiritual
interior self and your relationship to
spirituality in general right that that
can't be solved through relationship
with another human being no no I think
that is the you know crux of of
suffering for a lot of people it's good
to have that it's good for to have some
principles of like you know so next time
I find myself going Laura will you do
this why didn't you do that I won this
like the tail that's that thing that's
never gonna work you're doing again and
every time I sell it to myself as year
but though this time I am actually right
really my relationship with other people
is an opportunity to be of service it's
not an opportunity
he said perfectionism is definitely the
enemy of creation you know and so lately
you know what I have found is really
helpful is I just have these blocks of
time I also have a kid now so I really
have to commit to you know a block of
time because my time it's just not my
own anymore it belongs to my family
and I sit down and instead of vaguely
pondering is this idea really the one
that I want to follow I guess I could
like I just have stopped being
wishy-washy and I go with the first
thought and I follow it and I you know I
really shove perfectionism out the door
and I just I just try to finish the
thing mm-hmm and I think there's also a
luxury that comes with being an artist
who has made a lot of [ __ ] because once
you've made a lot of [ __ ] you're not so
precious about each and every little
offering because there's thousands of
them out there you know when you've only
offered the world five or ten songs you
know any given song is going to be a
huge percentage of your catalogue so
you're way more precious about it but
once you've proven yourself time and
time again you've written hundreds of
great songs like whether or not this
next song is the best thing you've ever
written isn't very important yeah yeah
yeah you want it if you you still hope
if you are if you are gonna do a second
TED talk though right like because that
was such a sensation write it that it's
like that that one-hit-wonder thing like
can I repeat that can I get catch
lightning in a bottle again would be
probably a different but oh my god yeah
give me give me another I mean I've got
ten TED talks I could do I'd love to do
a TED talk about patronage yeah and the
relationship over time through history
and into the future about our lack of
imagination around helping each other
I'd love to give its head talk about
miscarriage I'd love to give a TED talk
about childbirth I'd love to give it TED
talk about the stupid rules around
breastfeeding like I could just go on
and on
I just don't really want to do that
right now yeah well can we talk about
patronage though we can talk about
anything yeah like I said at the outset
like your relationship with your
audiences is like something I've never
seen before
and it really and I've heard you speak
about this like your how you think about
the how you think about patronage and
the relationship is unique but it's also
more ancient right like what's what's
not functional is the relationship of
industry to artists now and how we think
about what that exchange looks like and
yours is one of depth and not over
breadth right where the industry kind of
is driven by breadth in terms of like
how big is your audience how many can
you sell and all of that rather than the
intimacy and the connection that you can
create with the people that are super
into what you're doing sure because
capitalism I mean we're all it's just
like what's going on with the rest of
the country and the problems that we're
running into everywhere which is it's
not about it's not always about growth
it's not always about being the biggest
and the best and you know where we've
really been fed a painfully unhealthy
diet of unsustainable ways of being and
that all of that applies to the art
world elaborate I mean I grew up
watching MTV that was my education and
what it meant to be a performer and a
musician
you know I was like raised on at the
altar of Prince and Madonna and the
Michael Jackson and you know these
massive mega stars were you know my
guiding light like that's where you're
supposed to head be massive that's
that's what success looks like I didn't
have many models even in my immediate
little community
of musicians just making a living you
know musicians just helping out their
tribe I'm their tribe members with you
know small helpful connective
reflections of what life in this town
was like of what you know what we are
going through now and you know wind the
clock back a little bit and that's how
human beings have been using art and
music for thousands of years this scale
thing that we have just been
experiencing in this teeny sliver of
human time is bananas well we we forget
and this is what you reminded me of is
that we forget that art and music really
had nothing to do with Commerce no and
and and we're never supposed to yeah art
music for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years of human history were
just useful tools of the tribe yeah we
needed it for ritual for grieving for
transition for celebration none of that
was about selling [ __ ] right there's
about doing and being and connecting and
so how did how do you think we lost that
initially I mean you get capitalism and
money in the mix and things start to get
very weird very fast yeah but we're in
this interesting time now where you know
in the MTV era you're look you're either
you either have a video on MTV or you're
on the radio or nobody could possibly
have any sense of what you were doing
yeah that's all changed everything has
been disintermediated the middle man and
the gatekeepers are now gone everybody
can be a creator and distribute their
wares worldwide and you know the the
the possibility that you can be this
massive band that you know that that
isn't even really a reality except for a
few acts these days anyway so it's
always true I mean and what I have found
fascinating is how little things have
changed because I think it's foolhardy
to say that the the the gatekeepers are
gone they've just shifted faces
and you know we still have our mega pop
stars they're just you know the gates
have just sort of changed materials and
you know in this era we still have
massive Stadium pop stars and giant
machines and we you know we just we've
just sort of shifted the way those
people climb up the ladders and they
climb to the top of the mountain but
they still climb to the top of the
mountain you still good right but I
think that the infrastructure is still
fractured you know like you said in your
book like we are the media like that's a
radical concept that's also very true
and we're still in the very early stages
of that but it's undeniable you know
with you leading the charge and we're
seeing more and more people kind of
blaze this the past similar to yours
that this is the future like finding
your tribe and honoring that is the path
yeah and I mean I I adopted the internet
really early on as a community tool but
none of us saw any of this stuff coming
you know none of us back in you know
2000 2005 era could have forecasted that
in 2019 we would be talking about deep
fakes and talking about you know and
looking at a generation of kids who it's
very possible we'll never trust an image
yeah or even a moving image because who
knows if that image is really real and
their cultural literacy their media
literacy is gonna be so different from
yours and mine you know we grew up in an
era where like if you saw someone saying
and on a TV it was obviously happen yeah
that's not true anymore yeah so playing
that out like what does that look like
very serene I don't know and if I had
the answer oh my god like that would be
my TED talk I don't have an answer um
but I do think you know it's all for me
with music and art it's always gonna
circle back to why we needed it in the
first place the platforms will change
who we trust will change the middlemen
will change the gatekeepers the filters
will change but why we do it and why we
need to feel it that will not change
you're someone who you know feel
strongly about your private life and
you're not one to go out and do all the
talk shows and all that kind of stuff
but but you've really embraced in the in
the kind of press junket with this movie
you've embraced the podcast for me
you've done a lot of the big shows and I
think it's well suited to you because it
provides space to have a nuanced mature
the whole conversation about the things
that that you care about and I think
that that is you know part and parcel it
is reflected in the kind of movies that
that you like to make and certainly in
this movie well thanks I mean here's an
interesting thing though I don't think
it's a bad thing that you haven't seen
the film and maybe we'll come with our
friends tomorrow night and then we talk
about it more but I actually think it's
kind of it's nice in a funny way today
because we're recording this the day the
there today's opening day and and only
because just knowing what I know about
your own work and story I think it's
interesting to talk about it a little
bit like this but then but not worry
about what the films about per se or
even the process in making it because
I've been talking about that a fair
amount right what's what's more
interesting today is a walk in and
you've got like David Lynch catching the
big fish which I've loved and egos the
enemy which I haven't read what I think
is really fascinating is literally what
I'm going through today that is
different from any of these other
conversations and that I think I think
connects more back to things that I'm
really interested in about your own
let's call it like tipping point moment
of feeling like I need to pry our imeem
I need to shift my priorities but if I
go real base will not and I need to get
fit or but just really like I got to
shift my priorities is that the funny
thing is is I probably have not ever I
haven't I've threw myself into this as
much as anything I've done on a creative
level by simple virtual fact that I
wrote
I wrote it produced it directed it
raised all the money for it
it's 20 years in the making yeah it's a
long a long gestation on this one right
and I really and I really couldn't get
it out of my head it was not it was
really not at a certain point about like
the ego of I want to play this role it
really was it started to become for me
about things that I wanted to get across
that I started feeling actually the very
best feeling that you get about a thing
which is like it's and this I have
talked about but it's the Joseph
Campbell transparency effect it's like
this that people will be able to see
themselves in this they will be able to
see us in this they'll be reminded
they'll be able to see echoes of the now
but also like truths about the past and
how we got where we are and and even
just on a personal level reconnect with
empathy which is I think really really
important right now but mostly I'd it
mostly I just wanted to
I get stubborn about not completing the
thing and I really wanted to complete it
and so I did and so I've thrown myself
out there to talk about it right
way more than I generally know do or
want to because I really do think it's
better for people to figure stuff out on
their own mm-hmm however here's the
really interesting today which is I kind
of was intimating this to you in the
kitchen but the funny thing is is for
all the every form of cultivation we
didn't have there's it's not a ton of
financial support behind putting it out
they've done a good job but it's just
not the kind of film that you if you
throw a hundred million dollars in
marketing in a film like this you're
gonna lose 50 million bucks you know
that's just the way it is so I don't
expect that so I've tried to lean into
it but what's really interesting is I
know for sure already today that if not
gonna blow the doors off it's not gonna
be some it's not only not gonna be that
some record weekend it's not those
things it'll be soft
like it'll be it'll be less than then
people hoped it would do in an opening
weekend right
so this worried time is its Tim to me in
almost every framework it's not only not
relevant to what I was trying to do when
I did it but I actually know now from
experience on film specifically that the
very best things I've done and I mean
literally the stuff I've been nominated
for Oscars for the stuff that I haven't
but that people will almost ubiquitously
call cultural touchstones like Fight
Club or American History X or the 25th
hour or none of which got any awards or
anything like that but are generally the
first things named yeah if people say
these things right every single one of
those you've been down this road many
times when I see down this road what I
mean is a considered a financial failure
in the initial assessment of the matrix
of like measuring things by the amount
of right initial box office they do
right but not by the main metric or the
most important metric which is did we do
what we set out to do yes we say what we
wanted to say yes we the team that
created this thing satisfied that we
accomplished what we you know set out
absolutely but what I'm saying is what's
fascinating to walk in and see this book
is I I have been through it like I've
been through it I've actually
experienced the very rare satisfaction
of going through the feeling of
disappointment like when Fight Club came
out we all thought we made a right but
ass-kicker ever thought she did right
but it came out and everybody felt
stunned everybody felt stunned by that
it's so hard to believe that that was
the case yeah I know it was like booed
it was but also it just it just you know
it the budget the film it's like 68
million bucks and I think it's total box
office in the US was under 40 which
means the studio took home 20 so your
earring to like deep in the red yeah not
like partially in the red like deep in
the red right that was the air
not to get business wonky but the
studios still owned the DVDs and the
DVDs on Fight Club actually made in my
understanding ended up making it sort of
a profitable enterprise but it still it
was still like wow yeah Wow like we felt
the kind of heat we felt from the people
who loved it was like a once-in-a-career
kinda it was like that feeling of like
people get it they love it there their
feel so connected to it the level of
passion in that movie you know if you're
Gen X if you're a Gen X male I mean that
movie was transcended it's one of their
few movies I go back and watch every
single year and it's it's one of the
most impactful movies I've ever seen in
terms of like what I connect with
emotionally and in my opinion it comes
it and it takes you to a positive place
it takes you through the sexiness of
nihilism but back out to where he grabs
that he rejects that he grabs the girl's
hand and he says let's let's like let's
try this a healthier way right you know
there's definitely an embrace of chaos
and anarchy sure sure on the way I think
to saving Elaine from the church and and
running you know it's the same as the
end of the Graduate I really believe
that yeah but but but my point is we
went through that we felt stunned we
came out the back side of it and you
knew that was gonna happen going no we
didn't you know we didn't we felt we
didn't brats say to you like people
believe but you can't leave is what I
mean about you got you you still go like
God we we thought we made a hit movie
you know we thought made a hit movie and
it's sort of like in some matrix that's
not even the matrix that we care about
that that matrix tagging it as a
disappointment reverberates out it hits
you in the head and you go ahead like
like you questioned yours yeah we didn't
we didn't yeah that sucks like you feel
bad about something that in your heart
you feel good about right and I think
but my point is that even having been
through it when we talk about like the
ego being one of the most pernicious
addictions it's like I've been through
it multiple times like multiple times
you know what I mean and this film that
I've made it's
as good as anything I've done like just
full stop I know it is and I also you
know I did people Michael Eric Dyson
he's a sociologist to Georgetown you
just wrote a [ __ ] essay on it that
hit me out of the blue I was crying when
I read that was an esquire piece yeah
it's an incredible article it's and
partially about the film but it's also
partially about what it inspired in him
to think about race in America and Ken
Burns wrote this essay yeah
about it that I had me I was I was on
the floor he's a hero of mine and I'm
like there's this whole side of me right
now that's like I did what I said and
have phrased the movie more highly no
you didn't know medium article and I
Anna and what and it and there's a big
part of me that's like it's literally
like Chinatown it's like that the
psychic Carter the Jake gets in my house
is set in my head is saying he's saying
how much is enough like how much more do
you need like what more could you want
and the answer the best part of me is
for sure nothing like that's it that's
what you're going for you're going for
activation pleasure and activation and
is that happening it's happening I can
feel it I can see it and this will find
its level and people will get to it and
all these things but on a day when the
distribution head at Warner Brothers
calling you up and saying it's gonna be
a little softer then we want despite our
best efforts and your brain just slams
you and I don't mean like goes yeah okay
but you know hang you you know gotta
hang in there you're saying all these
things like it literally becomes like a
Tourette ik conversation right you can
you're saying these things and you
there's a voice that goes but yeah well
we're playing with this plays out on a
longer horizon this is like but still
there's a new economy a little resolute
there's a residue from that right but
this is what's interesting to me this is
what's totally fascinating to me is it's
not a residue it's a big [ __ ] loud
frustrated side of your head that is the
ego and goes [ __ ] I I wanted I wanted F
I wanted everyone else's version of of
what we want to be fulfilled to
my favorite line that I ever wrote in
all these books is the last line of tell
me more and it's your profoundly
ordinary kid is singing in the shower
and you get to be here to hear it yeah
and in the context of that book which
was written in the wake of losing my dad
and then losing my good friend Liz and
giving a eulogy in front of her three
kids eight ten and twelve and then going
home and having my kids get in a big
fight at the dinner table and then my
daughter kind of storming off and then
she was in the shower and then I heard
something and then I went upstairs and
then I kind of leaned my ear against the
door and I heard all the single ladies
all the single ladies and it was like I
get to be here they're like I get to
listen to this kids sing in the shower
and whatever that means for you that's
what it means but for me it was like
head to toe chills like I was so hyper
aware you know how you are after a loss
and it fades and that's partly what tell
me more about - it's like how difficult
it is to kind of hold that clarity and
live in that space and not return to
your normal crappy self who's pissed off
about gaining weight or getting a
parking ticket but it that moment of
standing outside that door was like Liz
will not have this moment she will not
get this moment she will not listen to
her 15 year old singing Beyonce in the
shower and I'm here and to be able to be
present and aware of the import of that
which is such a fleeting thing it's so
difficult for us as human beings to hold
on to that truth right and and that is
what the book is about it's sort of like
you you know navigating the aftermath of
your father and your friend housing away
and and grappling with your frustration
or perhaps on some level shame for not
being able to kind of you know maintain
that level of gratitude throughout like
constantly having to remind yourself but
defaulting to just the daily grind yeah
well you know it's interesting so that
the book is built around these
twelve things that I feel like we have
to be able to say to one another and to
ourselves to be adults in the world to
be in permanent relationship and the
first one is the most unusual and it's
this thing that this mindfulness guy
taught me so I was working at my
husband's I was writing at my husband's
startup it's called medium and it's a
total class see I'm still startup now I
guess so ev Williams who started it and
you know would let me come and and write
there is very generous and open the
doors to two writers in the area and so
I would come and you know I was like
total classic San Francisco startup like
kombucha bar meatless Mondays nap pods
mmm which I'm pretty sure it's like
where the Millennials are getting it on
and then they had this mindfulness guys
names will kabobs in who would be an
amazing guest for you
he's Jon kabat-zinn son right yeah who
wrote wherever you go there you are
and um so anyway he would lead these
sessions so I just like plopped in there
right next to EV as if I was like a real
employee and this guy to do this little
talk before we meditated about it's like
this and I didn't totally know what he
meant but I felt like it resonated on
that level that like a song lyric might
resonate where you wouldn't even want to
parse it you just want to like sit with
it and hold it and put it in your wallet
and so I kept thinking about it and then
I actually ended up in a long
conversation with them and I said you
know I have these moments where I
totally lose track of what matters and I
have and I have these moments where I
it's crystal clear and they're so
precious and I want to hold them and I
can't and he said it's like this mmm
and he said when do you lose track and I
said well here's an ordinary Monday
morning at our house so I have these two
kids and a husband and they are eating
breakfast at the table and then they're
very busy people and so they don't have
time to put the dishes in the sink but I
do so I
the dishes over and I'm already like
starting to feel steamed about that and
then they're gone and then I go back to
the kitchen table where I serve this
like organic food that I buy at a
grocery store that really irritates me
and on the kitchen table is a little
teeny pile of cut toenails
uh-huh and that just took me over the
edge in dignity the indignity I mean do
you have cut on it like have you ever
cleaned up somebody's cat toenails Oh
everything has everybody cleaned up
somebody's cut toenails is that what I
don't understand about that well it's
just it's just the idea you know look
kids at a certain age it's just they
just they just do what they do and then
they walk away right and the implicit
message as the parent is always like
okay so I'm here I'm the one who's
supposed to clean all this up right it's
like a daily thing yeah and then but the
only way out of course is to realize
that it's like this like that there are
the and and if you don't mind I'll just
read the end of it please
chapter because because what I was
feeling was that well well after the cut
toenail thing then I this UPS guy came
who is like aggressively fit like you
fit and I am not fit and I do not
exercise and I do hope that during this
conversation today you can persuade me
they liked you their turn over a new
leaf I think you're doing fine oh that's
terrible it's terrible I'm gonna age so
badly anyway put a pin in that so anyway
the guy comes and he gives me this
little envelope and it's from j.crew and
then I remember that I bought this
t-shirt this little linen top and then I
realized that like linen has no stretch
in it there's no lycra but there's like
ER and almost everything else so I don't
really know what size I am anymore
you know cuz maybe I'm a six but maybe
I'm a twelve because I've been wearing
stretchy clothes for like 15 there's the
size we tell people that we are and then
there's the real size that we are yeah
your driver's license waiting right so
speak so anyway I go upstairs I put this
shirt on and then I can't literally
can't get it off and I had to cut it off
with scissors so I'm I'm fit to be tied
I'm like staring at myself and my new
stupid vest in the mirror and I relaxed
my face I exhale I can sole my
reflection it's like this Kelly this is
how it goes
hidden in the mornings frustrations like
a rattlesnake in the woodpile is
something else I close my eyes so I can
listen for the other thing the further
away much worse thing in the quiet of my
own head life ends
I've known this since the summer of 1972
when an ambulance drove away in silence
with the old lady down the street who
gave out almond joys on Halloween but
now I've seen mortality do it's awful
ghosting up close twice and that has
changed the context of everything in the
new zodiac without greenie my dad
without Liz all terms have been
recalibrated pain is agony bad is fatal
the scale is reset making it hard for me
to reconcile what I've seen with how I
live Liz would have done a week of
aggressive bromodomain inhibitors at
cedars-sinai for one morning of
hairballs eggshells and toenail
clippings to see her kids become
teenagers screaming obscenities at each
other in the hall she'd have given up
every organ in her pelvic cavity then
there's greenie who would have told you
that life was a carnival all music and
snacks dolls fortune tellers and
strongmen it's magical lovey Edward my
husband called greeni
a happiness genius but ask anyone he was
as excited about being alive as anyone
you'll ever meet this isn't just a kid
making a hero out of her dad and me I
walked next to him in that festival
light for almost 50 years
and then one night in February his hand
went still in mine and Here I am same as
ever
except quicker to anger and 13 pounds
heavier shouldn't loss change a person
for the better forever
maybe wills curious phrase it's like
this applies here to this forgetting
this slide into smallness this
irritability and shame this disorienting
grief it's like this minds don't rest
they reel and wander and fixate and roll
back and reconsider because it's like
this having a mind heart stone Idol
they swell and constrict and break and
forgive and behold because it's like
this having a heart lives don't last
they thrill and confound and circle and
overflow and disappear because it's like
this having a life beautiful there's so
much in there and I'll talk about I know
but sad acceptance that that you are not
going to be able to hold it right that's
huge that was freedom and it releases
you from that pressure that you feel or
that guilt that you Harbor that you're
supposed to be other than what you are
yes and the self looks think that comes
with it because it is really astonishing
to stand in front of a congregation of
people and give a eulogy for a young
person and then ever be mad again does
not seem to go together like I guess I
had sky-high expectations that I would
forever consistently and constantly be
different and you're not you're not and
that's weird it feels like you're
dishonouring this memory of this person
yeah I mean it's it's it's sort of a
comfort to hear that it's just like this
and yet it leaves me wondering well why
does it have to be this way
like why are we why is the human mind
soul spirit wired in that way like what
how is it possible that you know two
hours after some life-changing
experience you could get into a road
rage or you know distract yourself with
you know some small indignity and then
beat yourself up for it to make it even
worse so I blame our neurobiology like a
and by that I mean the way that we have
evolved as a species to survive under
the circumstances as they've changed
over thousands of years and I think it's
astonishing the levels at which we are
operating at any given moment like I
could be having
this very deep conversation with you at
the same time that I'm thinking I would
like to floss my teeth uh-huh I would
like to drink this water in front of me
but I don't want to make any noise
uh-huh I hope that reading wasn't too
long for rich I wonder if other authors
do readings on here whether I just
totally bugged him like I can hold in my
head and in my heart
simultaneously I'm gonna say two dozen
different discrete thoughts that are
operating at different discrete levels
huh that's really something to marvel at
and accept as the truth of our machine
like this is what our machine does this
is how the machine works and so I'm a
tech guy I mean I'm a computer scientist
I'm an Internet nerd I was using the net
before you know there was worldwide web
browsers I've been blogging for over a
decade and so I looked at certain things
like social media platforms and to me
it's junk food and so I don't see it as
a stance of you know neo-luddism to say
for example I don't use Facebook I see
it more like saying I don't eat Doritos
mm-hmm and that you can you can love
tech like I do but not necessarily
embrace all of the trends and so that's
a lot of the message I'm out there out
there preaching is that you have to be
intentional you have to be selective
yeah how do you counter the argument
that you know just leveraging my own
personal experience like I I'm totally
on board with everything you're saying
and yet I can't deny that social media
has benefited me in certain ways like it
is created the foundation upon which
I've created my career in many ways and
it's allowed me to connect with and
contact a lot of interesting people that
are now like friends of mine and you
know in my inner ear IRL in my real life
yeah well I mean this is part of the
issue when you're talking about things
like social media is that in some sense
the the people from whom you might be
hearing about these topics is actually a
pretty rarefied group right so so it's
people that maybe have large media
brands right I mean so this is core
perhaps to your business you you have a
sort of a large brand and a lot of
businesses use social media very
successfully there's a reason why
Facebook is worth 500 billion dollars
you know for
example if you're trying to advertise
it's like a miracle what right what
Facebook allows you to do but I don't
know that circumstance applies to most
people mm-hmm right I mean so for a lot
of people I mean they're trying to
whatever they're trying to connect more
with their family or community they're
trying to do well by their do well by
their job they're trying to build a life
that it has certain elements of meaning
to it they maybe don't need or have any
reason to have a large audience and yet
they still feel compelled well I think I
just need to vaguely be on these
services mm-hmm and then they step back
and look at what's going on and they
realize it's it's one to three hours a
day that they're they're glancing at
these things so at the core of
minimalism for example is this notion of
there's no good or bad tech but
intentions are really useful so the
solution right rather than becoming a
neo-luddite or a denialist you have this
idea of digital minimalism that's really
routed in orienting your digital diet
around your core values yeah so you know
elaborate on that for me right well I
mean minimalism itself is an old idea so
you can go all the way back to Marcus
Aurelius and this whole through line
through the ancients into Thoreau into
the voluntary simplicity movement of the
1960s
it's a through line right and so
minimalism itself is this ancient idea
that can apply to lots of different
things and the basic idea behind
minimalism is in many cases it's better
to focus most of your energy on a small
number of things that give you a large
amount of value as opposed to the
alternative which is maximalism which is
trying to spread your energy over
everything you can find it might give
you some value mm-hmm and so these two
things are set up this is like a
dialectic right you have minimalism and
maximalism and so in all different parts
of our life the sages have told us
minimalism less is more is better than
trying to spread your attention widely
so I'm just bringing minimalism into
people's digital personal life basically
right talk a little bit about the
importance of solitude so solitude is an
interesting idea
it has different definitions but the the
one that caught my attention came from
another book called lead yourself first
which was about solitude and leadership
but the definition that these guys used
which was it's actually an army officer
a really well-known Circuit Court judge
federal judge
so it's interesting pair of guys that
came together the right about salted
this judge actually he does he writes
his legal briefs in a barn in Michigan
that has no internet so she's after my
own heart
but anyways right they had this
definition of solitude and they said
it's not don't think about it having to
do with physical isolation right don't
think about you know are you alone on a
mountainside or not they said it all has
to do with what you're processing and so
their definition was freedom solitude is
freedom from input from other minds so
if you're processing something that was
generated from another mind you're not
in a state of solitude anytime you're
looking at this or any time you have the
earbuds in unless it's music if you're
listening to something if you're reading
something if you're talking to someone
it's not a state of solitude your your
brain is in input processing mode our
brain takes very seriously the idea that
okay this input we're getting right now
came from another human being and that
turns on all sorts of different centers
that don't turn on when you're just
let's say looking around at nature right
if you're not doing that you are in
solitude so you can be in a very crowded
coffee shop but if you're just sitting
there alone with your own thoughts
you're in a state of solitude so there's
nothing to do with with physical
isolation and why is it important so it
turns out it's it's crucial for humans
to have solitude on a regular basis one
is just maintenance mode I mean it takes
a lot of power for our brain to okay all
hands on deck like we're processing you
know there's another human mind that
we're processing right now all hands on
deck right we've got fire up all these
systems it's complicated right
like when I'm talking to you right now
one of the things my brain is doing some
of the research I got into is something
called mentalizing which means I'm
building a simulation of your brain
within my own brain so that I could then
start doing experiments in my own mind
of you know how is my ritual simulation
going to react if I say this versus this
it's incredibly complicated it used a
lot of energy right so if you're always
doing that the brain doesn't get down
cycles right so you're gonna get anxiety
other types of issues it's also crucial
for self development and insight
generation you know if our brain is in
processing mode it can't actually be
making sense in any sort of significant
degree of the information that is
processing and so you know someone
listening to this interview is an
processing mode if they really want to
get insights out of it what they also
then need is after they hear this
interview sometime just alone with their
thoughts thinking about what they heard
mm-hmm and and that's when the brain
makes sense of it right and compares the
insights against their own mental schema
as their own understanding of the world
figuring out where it might apply or not
fit into their life
you also need it for personal
development you can't have insights into
what am i all about what are my values
how's my character can develop what do I
want to do going forward all of that
requires solitude your brain just has to
sit there have to think things have to
bounce off of each other like we need it
but I think a lot of people would
contend that it's a luxury right like
I'm just look man you know I got I got I
got you if you have a bunch of kids like
I got kids you know I'm going to my work
I'm trying to make money I'm trying to
get through the day like I don't have
time for solitude and that
self-reflection is the purview of you
know somebody's living a life that's not
mine yeah well see I think that's
because we've put solitude on this
pedestal and we think about the row in
his cabin all right like what am I gonna
what am I gonna have time today to get
out to my cabin and but there's an
illusion about that as well that you
talked about in the book yeah which is a
not really what he was up to but we're
no busier now than we were 10 years ago
but 10 years ago we had lots of solitude
and the reason is is that when you have
this precise definition a solitude all
you need is freedom from input from
other minds this used to happen all the
time you couldn't avoid it it's you know
there's nothing on the radio and you're
driving the work solitude you're waiting
in line at the pharmacy it's solid you
right now you look at that person you're
like what's wrong with it that's wrong
with them right and so that's what's so
unique about this current circumstance
is what I mentioned before is now that
we can pull out this wirelessly
connected device
everywhere we can banish all those
moments of solitude so what's weird is
not the call for solitude to think
that's very very unusual is the fact
that we have banished solitude
that's what's incredibly rare in the
entire history of of sort of human
civilization is there's only like seven
or eight years old this idea that is now
possible they get rid of all solitude so
to get souls in your life is as easy as
just some of the places where you used
to have it even when you're really busy
you get it back by just not using your
phone so okay on my commute today I'm
not going to put on the
the podcast for the first 20 minutes or
when I'm walking a dog I'm not putting
into the earbuds when I go to the store
I'm leaving the phone in the car right
so it's it's stuff that you're already
doing just do some of those things
without the slot machine and the
constant access to solitude you know
busting information for better or worse
worse or like it or not I mean you and I
are very different individuals we are
maybe extremely different and somehow we
have been put together by divine mother
for this journey that has ignited some
inspiration some vision for you know for
many who you know write to us who want
to know how we are in relationship and
the fact that we are so extreme that you
know sort of everything about the way we
walk the earth is completely different
the way we approach the earth the way we
experience life and I'm looking for now
this next level of evolution and
expansion when we are truly igniting
both feminine and masculine energies
within ourselves and as we access these
greater energies of fully stepping into
our power how does that look in a new
paradigm relationship and so we have
traces and aspects of this
prince/princess paradigm that we you
know we've that we've played into that
have worked for us and it is a human way
of relating man and wife and I feel like
we are on the precipice of writing a new
way of being relate in relationship and
and what does that mean and so for me to
be clear because I can see you're like
you're like can you make a list can you
no I'm not but I do want ya flush that
out so I know exactly what I mean I'm
looking for first of all more ceremony
in our marriage I'm look but I'm looking
for it not in not in that I'm doing it
and you're going along with it I'm
looking for a recognition and a knowing
of the power of ritual and ceremony and
as we move through life the letting go
of our habits of watching Netflix of
watching you know movies whatever those
humanly activities are that that gather
our attention for a moment I'm looking
for an expansion into really
understanding that a life is precious
and every moment we spend is precious
and now that we know that we've been
given the privilege of being in this
space of having an audience of having
people that we can commune with really
committing to using that time and using
that time in relationship so we're back
to the anniversary no date no
celebration the reason why I wasn't
really attached to it is I didn't want
to go to dinner with you I don't want to
go to a movie with you I don't want to
go do some typical anniversary esque you
know I don't want a dozen roses from you
I want to go on the side of a cliff and
like take our clothes off and you know
right as you know light a ceremonial
fire not really because their fires
around here but you know what I'm saying
I mean I want to explore what can we
really do together that's beyond I've
gone to enough dinners
I've had enough roses I don't need to go
to another dinner I don't need to go to
we can't even go to hotel room because
you sleep in a tent so unless we bring
the tent to the hotel right no I get
what you're saying
so do you okay yeah and I and I'm I'm up
for that you know I'm up for that new
experience and I think it would it would
cultivate a an enhanced level of
intimacy that would take us into this
next chapter and I think just doing a
retrospective on on you know where we're
at and how we got here I look at it like
this we we got together for whatever
reason to co-create we committed to this
path less trodden we underwent
difficulties we burned in the fire
almost died yeah to emerge from that
and then we're presented with
opportunities that I think over the last
seven years whatever it is eight years I
have just worked my ass off to
capitalize on in order to create
stability for the family and also almost
as in immense for the trauma that
preceded it and to prove to myself that
I could be a successful productive
member of society which is something I
had previously struggled with my entire
life or at least beginning when I
started started drinking and I've been
in kind of crisis mode for that entire
eight-year period just trying to make it
work and now we've emerged from that
with a situation that is successful its
staple I've got this platform I'm able
to provide for the family and
essentially I'm in this incredibly
privileged rare situation where I get to
make choices about where I want to place
my energy and make money like I am
essentially in control of that but I'm
still operating day-to-day like I'm in
that triage situation and this has been
impressed upon me by many people to just
listen you you can take a minute here
and breathe and relax and I'm like yeah
but I got to do this and then this is
happening and it's like yeah five years
ago you had to be that way maybe two
years ago you had to be that way but now
you don't have to be that way and what
is it all worth if you can't really feel
gratitude moments a moment for what you
have co-created and to be present in
your own life and that's something that
I definitely struggle with moment to
moment and something that I want to be
able to embrace and bring into my life
in a more meaningful way and it's that's
a challenge for me you know because I'm
running I'm
this program and the fear associated
with flipping the switch and doing it a
different way gets associated in my mind
with stopping you know like an arresting
of the things that got me here right
like this is the way I do it and this is
what's working to do it anyway
differently would mean risking capsizing
the whole thing well first of all I want
to say thank you that you have done an
extraordinary job of coming into this
level of expression and it's absolutely
beautiful to see and it's breathtaking
and that has been an amazing experience
for all of us definitely I would also
say again that in a human format we like
to make a list and say from the brain
that we have all these things to do
first and then we'll get to the
spirituality and so what we have to
remember and what I will remind you is
it is the purity of this relationship
that fruited this entire drama the
entire thing that we're doing so it
started on a very special day well it
started before but the day that we
actually were married it was a spiritual
world concert there were channelers
bhagavad das kirtan gospel singers
african wedding dancers and it literally
was all about spirituality and it was
one of the most beautiful days in my
life I posted it on her anniversary on
my Instagram feed that ceremony is what
was the intention that created what we
experienced now are you connected with
that yeah okay
so what I'm saying is that I just wanted
to check in every ass you're like yeah I
was okay no it it is that level of
desire of devotion it's really this
devotion this this this love affair with
life the love affair with the wonder of
life and what is pulsing through each
one of us in all life and so what I
would say to you is that you don't have
to change the format of how you run the
podcast I mean sure you can shift and
all that and you know we're going to be
taking some time off in December which
is magnificent so all of that is great
but I guess what I'm talking to more is
in the day-to-day of how you go about
your day I know there is time that is
spent either in this for all of us I'm
not like judging I'm just saying it's
social media it's scrolling through
Twitter it's Netflix it's it's stuff
that we do out of habit stuff that we do
out of habit and this would be good for
everybody what if we all made a list for
the next week of things we do out of
habit that are not high vibrational
activities that are furthering the life
that are actually met being medicated or
being suppressed or controlled by the
society to check out what we are serving
as medication yeah but we just do it by
default because we don't really even
we're not really thinking of it we're
like okay I worked a hard day now I
deserve an episode of Han man's head
mates today because I just want to
distract myself and I just want to
breathe and just can I just not think
about my life right now and invest in
some story that all that'll lull me into
a sleep state but what if you like chose
let's not ask you to give it all up
let's just say if just one day a week
there was a two-hour time period where
you turned all the lights off and turned
on a candle and you actually communed
with the greater being that you are and
you were like you know like when I sit
in that it's like you know leave me
guide me direct me reveal yourself to me
like reveal the path to me I'm here I'm
here
I'm listening
if we don't reconnect to nature will
this destroy it again I want I want to
try to bring this to some sort of
closure that doesn't feel like I'm the
most depressing person you've ever
listened to you and so I'm kind of
battling in my mind now to kind of get
us back to the space where we can say it
is doomed it's like I'm bright all the
optimism like I don't really know where
you don't know where to go at this one
um so let me take you back to kind of
where how do you reconcile those two
things and I do it actually through my
experience as a physician in the ICUs
and in the ICU is when I was practicing
intensive Hospital medicine I got the
privilege of being around human beings
at the end of life and I was so
compelled by this experience that I
ended up getting another subspecialty in
hospice and palliative care and dealing
with end-of-life things for for four
years with a hospice group and at the
end of a life we've termed it death and
what I've laid out for you today is the
possibility of the death of our species
in seventy years hundred years who cares
it was 200 years it's still pathetic and
so we have we're looking at the last
chapter of life on earth with our
current course of action but let me tell
you about what my experience has been in
those last moments with patients who are
dying we have the belief I think in our
subconscious because of the movies we
watch because of the TV shows we watch
because of our our big divorce from the
death process it's become sterilized you
have probably not seen many people die
you've probably not seen your loved ones
die on they've probably died you know
operating rooms or a nice use or and
they died before you could fly across
the country and see them or be and so
very few human beings are now watching
this process of death and it's allowed
death to be defined as a as an endpoint
as a contraction or disappearance rather
than what I would have actually seen it
to be and what I've seen it to be is a
massive expansion of consciousness of
reality of awareness and ultimately of
love
and the most poignant examples of this
or people that actually die biologically
and we spend 15 or 30 minutes and ICU
resuscitating them with drugs and
shocking their chests like you see on TV
shows and everything else and we have a
dismal track record of pulling those
people act it's not like TV we lose the
vast majority its around 6 percent of
cardiac arrests and in the hospital will
actually be resuscitated and 6 percent
will survive 94 percent will die so you
have somebody who's now biologically
dead and you're artificially sustaining
life you've got them on a respirator and
you're pounding on their chest and press
and you're pumping drugs in their brain
to try to get their heart restarted and
doing all of this and they've meanwhile
been in the ICU for a week or a few days
or weeks months in some cases before
they they have this moment and by this
time they've been isolated away from
humans for quite some time they're only
touched by latex gloves hands
only people with gowns on will come and
see them that masks on they haven't seen
a human face close up in months you know
they're so isolated and lonely and they
go into this moment on the other side
and and then we start working on them
and doing our code and and as the hero
depicted on TV you become that doctor
that pulls somebody back from that that
other side of the veil and it was
startling as you know I moved past my
internship and started be kind of senior
resident these environments and really
responsible for being around these these
patients for hours after these
experiences they all told such a similar
story on the other side of biologic life
and I had to do with that a little bit
of a typical story that you said might
see in the movies or something where
they saw a white light and there's a
sense of expansion all this but there's
one sentence that that came back again
and again and I had one ICU shift that
was very weird I had the one ICU shift
where I worked for 36 hours shift and
during that that night and middle my
36-hour shift I see three people die and
I bring them all back when I sent my
team and to the last one of those three
every single one of them their first
sentence had was always why did you
bring me back which always kind of
deflated my and said that yeah
said why did you bring me back and and
the variety was huge one of these was an
african-american pastor had had over 200
visitors in his icy room in the days
before he passed away and the other one
was you know this very isolated kind of
ostracized
gentleman in his communities it was
dying of complications of AIDS and then
I had this kid who was who had genetic
defects and all this stuff and he was
dying of complications of pneumonia cuz
he couldn't breathe that anymore because
his skeleton to clout so you just
couldn't pick three different medical
cases or three different human beings
and every one of them first sentence
why'd you bring me back and then as they
start to get oriented and in the in the
hours that follow they're telling their
loved ones I went into this space and it
was bright white light everywhere and I
in that moment felt completely accepted
for the first time in my life and that
was a unexpected sentence to hear out of
multiple accounts I felt completely
accepted for the first time in my life
so what do you make of that I think
we're all walking around lonely as hell
and our opportunity to rebirth because
death is not not an endpoint it's a
transformation moment
it's an expansion beyond the limits of
this frail biologic shell that we carry
around and the instant that we step out
of that we find out that the universe
embraces us in every single second of
our existence and complete acceptance of
who we are we are enough in and of our
own identity of I am at every second of
every point of our existence and it's
the disbelief of that that's keeping us
locked in these stupid conversations we
just had for last hour and a half that
is myopic conversation in and of itself
when you back up for a moment say okay
we're killing ourselves but what if we
need a death moment to transform
completely to let go of all of the
preconceived notions of what it is to be
human and to say you know what we are
beings of light and we are completely
accepted at every mode including this
moment when we would rape the earth of
what it were raping you know when we
would kill each other at the rate we do
when we would destroy the entire
ecosystem of a green
planet in the middle of black space when
we would have that level of hubris we're
still completely accepted and our
journey is somehow understood by
something more benevolent and more
complete than we can see as human beings
and so let's not beat each other up over
this issue let's not see this as a
failure let's see this is an obvious
next step in our journey and death is
the inevitable thing marching Attis
that's going to say are you going to
wake up and see the transformation at
that moment of death and transformation
and you're going to say goodbye Homo
sapiens or gonna do it a moment before
that in the body before the doctor
starts the resuscitation are you gonna
say you know what what if we all looked
at each other in wonder and awe and said
you're enough I accept you completely I
want to be with you I want to live with
you I want to be a live period and if
it's with you then it must be on purpose
because we're in the same room and the
odds of that is zero and so we are here
seven billion of us showed up right now
which is really odd because I just laid
out a horrific story of what's happening
on the planet yet seven billion of those
white souls that seconds after death are
going to realize that they are who
they've always been they're fully
accepted and they are moving in true
love and and that white light is the
love and they're in that space what if
we can transform before we die then
there's no reason to go to Mars there's
no reason to go anywhere else because we
will do absolutely every single thing
differently here on earth and we do it
differently by just that simple
recognition of I am Who I am you are who
you are that's enough and I accept you
completely and let's figure out how to
do this within the design of nature
there's enough energy there's enough
food there's enough soil there's enough
commodities there's enough resources for
everybody on the planet to thrive at a
level that's never been experienced we
cannot continue any form of human
economic systems that have ever existed
before and expect us to escape the death
moment we literally have to reinvent
everything and so if you are under the
age of 18 right now you are the last
generation that may live to the fullest
extent of the human potential it is you
who are being called it's transformed
because you showed up right when you did
if my generation is to do anything it
was to say oh my gosh we're going in the
dry or on direction but my generation
doesn't have enough time now to turn the
boat around reinvent everything and so
our mission is not to inspire the
farmers that are currently fighting the
good fight it's to inspire their
children to do the right thing and do it
differently connected to new children
who are in the cities who are in the you
know tech world whoever wherever they
are connect those kids back give them a
sense of that unity give them a sense of
the oneness and give us all a sense that
this is the inescapable optimism as we
are going to transform period and it may
be I doubt of to the point of our death
or miraculously it might just happen
right before it that was one of the best
monologues I've ever heard of my life
pre-shift brother that was amazing oh my
god you're this incredible contradiction
in terms with the difference day and the
optimism and the deep-rooted experience
and knowledge in science and yet
somebody with a vast capacity for for
spiritual exploration you're a wizard
you're a gift all right we all are and
that's the excitement that I have is you
you can't actually come close to the
science of atomic physics or
astrophysics or human biology without an
overwhelming sense of we are just so far
beyond logic we're so far beyond the
material world we are these entities
that are moving with such power and we
have been kept from that power and we've
been kept from it so that power can be
taken from us and consolidate in the
hands of a few you know what we do what
I discovered and what became kissed the
ground with you know the cofounders of
finian and Lauren was was knowledge that
has been kept and under
many indigenous cultures around the
world many pioneering you know
pioneering farmers and permaculturist
sand you know this is wisdom that's been
in little pockets for a long time coming
from many places
you know we're standing on the shoulders
of that wisdom and we saw be that being
that we live in Los Angeles and you know
the the communications capital of the
world the trendsetting capital of the
world we said all right this is the most
exciting important idea inspiration
pathway we're going to tell this story
we want this to be a paradigm shift of
you know that we can actually go beyond
sustainability we can actually
regenerate and restore our soils we can
restore our biodiversity we can you know
have healthy food for you know the idea
that we can't feed the world on small
ish or even medium-sized farms is absurd
you know 40 percent of the food gets
wasted eighty percent of the food
feeding the total population comes from
small farms so walk me through that
because that's that's the thing and I
that I have difficulty wrapping my head
around I mean the conventional wisdom is
look if Kay foes do one thing it's that
they know how to drive economies of
scale like they take a super
concentrated you know number of animals
and they try to blow them up into food
using the least amount of time and
resources possible and they've kind of
perfected this right this is having a
huge deleterious impact on the planet
until suffering all kinds of terrible
issues with that nobody's a fan of this
but when I look at how many people are
on the planet and the forecast for you
know the 10 billion that are soon to
come and then I look at biodynamic
farming my first instinct is we don't
have enough land like you're you need
more space for these cattle like
certainly we're gonna have to reduce our
addiction to animal foods on some level
not everyone is going to
struck vegan but how can we scale up
this this wonderful practice that is
yeah I mean Oh sequestering carbon and
regenerating the earth and all of that
and do it in a way that actually is
gonna function in the modern world
totally I'd say you know my view is that
the the big billboard is we need to eat
more plants eat less meat as like the
the big the biggest billboard that as
far as where we are because 95% of the
meat that we're eating is you know just
a total train wreck but if we want to
get interested in the more nuts and
bolts of how to grow food in a way that
actually restores heals and not just you
know you know the the aspect of animals
and eating animals and animals role on
grasslands and keeping grasslands
healthy and ultimately when we're
talking about keeping grasslands healthy
we're talking about keeping land that
were growing grains for eating you know
without when we decoupled animals from
land we just put animals in barns and
then we put chemicals to boost the
nitrogen the NPK nitrogen potassium and
phosphorus as like the you know the
quick fix to grow to grow you know
grains and crops essentially the the
chemicals obviously started to degrade
the farmland in the last 40 years we've
lost we've lost 30 percent of the
farmland being grown to desertification
right so destroyed so the United Nations
said we have 60 years left under the
current system of harvests 60 seasons
left so we you know we have to we have
to scale way back I mean right now most
meat that we're eating is you know
coming from a total destruction system
right so we need to cut way back on that
we need to be eating you know more plant
rich diet
and then if we're if we're really
serious about how we can actually
restore and heal land and restore the
you know the broken soil you know
animals grazing on grass lands has an
amazing restorative effect and that is a
solution for those that are going to
continue to eat meat and that can be a
something that has a total full
environmental win for the planet and you
know it's showed that you know a CAFO
situation has total methane a lot of
greenhouse gases going up and a a
grazing situation where you have managed
grazing of animals on grassland you have
a net sequestration of carbon going even
you know the cow still produce methane
but within that overall system there is
a net sequestration of carbon and a
significant net sequestration of carbon
going into that land that's being
managed that way so the you know and a
lot of the land that across the country
is not fit for agriculture we don't want
to be telling it we want one of putting
handle grow crops so there's actually
and we've killed all the natural bison
or you know grazing animals oftentimes
that were on that land and so you know
there's this real live opportunity of
you know putting grazing animals back to
a good life and having a net beneficial
you know impact on that on that soil on
that grassland on that environment and
you know we're obviously you know
encouraging you know a less meat
consumption but for the people that are
going to eat me this is an opportunity
for that to have a beneficial impact and
again I get the morality aspect of you
know people not wanting to kill animals
and I love and respect that perspective
but for those that are those that are
choosing to eat meat here is a really a
win-win situation that can have
benefit for for for many stakeholders
yeah including you know the thing the
biggest thing that we don't have a
solution for which is how are we gonna
sequester enough carbon such that we
don't go into climate chaos yeah we need
some emergency actions right now we
really are running out of time and
things like the farm bill and these
subsidies are really preventing us from
embracing a solution that's right in
front of us like you know it seems to me
that if we could stop subsidizing the
you know the growing of all these crops
that go to feed and we can start
emphasizing biodynamic farming the price
of meats gonna go way up and that's
going to call the herd literally in
terms of like the number of humans that
can afford these meat products it's
going to drive down meat consumption and
make that possibility more realistic but
there doesn't seem to be any political
will for this that's the problem there
is there is not but I'll tell you since
since we started kissed the ground seven
years ago and we launched the soil story
which was the first piece of media that
we that you know that I had seen that
was like a three minute short synopsis
of regenerative agriculture and the
potential of it the amount of attention
and term people using the terminology
and the amount of investment going into
that space is been I mean it's still
it's still a drop in the bucket but you
know the fact that General Mills you
know making a public declaration people
could say all that's total green wash
you know a million acres you know by
2030 another startup called indigo just
committed to I think you know 10 million
acres under regenerative management and
they're wanting to pay farmers to
sequester carbon you know the the the
momentum that when we first started
talking about this it was very fringe
and and again I didn't know it you know
people like you know my understanding is
Al Gore people were very experts on you
know climate people you know Bill
McKibben you know had understanding of
this but they weren't standing like this
was a solution it was still too fringe
it wasn't but now
there's an article every week that's got
coming out talking about how farmers can
be a solution to climate change so the
first real pivotal moment though comes
at 12 or 13 when you have this doctor's
appointment so walk me up to that point
like prior to that was there some gender
confusion or were you convicted and
being a girl it was there some sense
that there I mean what was the reason
that you went to go see this doctor and
what happened right so I mean you know
kind of when you're your earliest
memories you know as you when you're a
kid you know six seven years old you
know that's kind of for me at least like
my first you know things when I look
back on and think about like how you
feel that's when I first remember
knowing or feeling that something was
different but at that age you're you're
just so like your idea of the world is
so basic and so you know minimal you
don't really like know what to make of
it so I always knew something was
different about myself even before you
know I found out that I was born
intersex and I could never you know put
my you know finger on it I could never
you know figure out what it was I would
you know I'd be in school and you know
I'd have my friends that were guys and
friends that were girls and I could you
know relate to you know both of them in
different ways but also kind of feel
like not really like fully be able to
relate and so that was always something
I you know I felt from a young age and
didn't know what it meant um so um you
know um yeah it's like 12 or 13 you know
you're going into middle school you have
to have your you know physical for
sports or whatever the case was so going
for a physical and the the nurse you
know you do live the whole you know body
examination and she could tell that my
body wasn't developing it you know as a
typical female would and she's like okay
we need to we need to check this out and
you know see what's going on and so go
up to OHSU which is a very reputable
hospital up in Portland
and yeah that's when I that's when I
discovered or they discovered through
ultrasound and blood tests and all that
stuff that I was born with androgen
insensitivity syndrome right so explain
what a is is so a is is a condition
there's there's like three different
conditions and it's intersex is like a
big like umbrella term for people that
are not born with an you know the
typical gender binary depending on you
know what's inside their body right it
can mean a lot of different it can take
you a long time yeah and they say it's
like one in two thousand which is true
but a is is more like I don't want to
misquote this but it's something like
one in two hundred thousand so it's it's
pretty rare but that still means there's
tens of thousands of people walk around
exactly yeah so in it so it can mean
different things so for me I was born
without any female reproductive parts
any you know female internally you know
sexual reproductive parts I was born
with male reproductive parts
reproductive parts and internally so
that's essentially but it was not
evident when you were born exactly so
and that's where it can kind of it can
kind of you know differ so sometimes
it's detectable at birth sometimes it's
not sometimes it's not detected until
puberty which was the case for me and
what's really not a good thing and
there's doctors are still doing this is
these babies that they detect you know
are born intersex are assigning genders
to these babies before you know they
grow up and are able to decide for
themselves who they want to be and so
you have these kids who are growing up
and sometimes you know the parents won't
even let them know that this happened
and Sylla grow up and be like I I don't
feel right something's you know
something's different I don't identify
with you know my gender and then they
come to find out that they were born
intersex and we're assigned a gender as
an infant so yeah well we live in a
binary dualistic society I mean if
you're born there's a birth certificate
and there's two boxes right so you gotta
check one of those yes exactly
yeah and that's yeah Matt that's
changing
I was just I was just telling Daniel did
um Oregon just passed not a law but
they're allowing people to identify as
the third gender on license on their
license when they're you know applying
to to get their license no you seen
you're seeing all these little things
that are you know coming coming into the
equation that are allowing people to be
a little bit more you know diverse we
write what they I do is yeah fluid
exactly I think it's important I mean
this comes into play when we're gonna
talk about sports don't line here but
not to conflate intersects with trans
like these are different things exactly
that's I think that's an important thing
the important thing to say because in
this is something that I've been trying
to kind of tiptoe around like is in
talking about this because I don't one
thing I don't want to do is alienate the
trans community and D legitimize you
know what they're feeling just because
it's not you know from a genetic
standpoint I was genetically born both
but that doesn't mean that someone that
wasn't genetically born you not you know
as they were born or who they were born
as that doesn't take away from how they
feel right just because they don't have
like a you know genetic you know thing
to back it up people just like nope this
is the way it is is how I feel about it
and I'm not changing my mind it's like
if everyone could just have an open mind
and be open to you know different
possibilities we would get we'd make a
lot more progress than we do the problem
is I think the overwhelming majority of
people are you know close minded and
aren't willing to shift their the way
they view things or the way they feel
about something because of their
experience and growing up or whatever
the case is and but I totally agree I
think as long as people have an open
mind we can we can eventually I don't
know when but we will eventually get to
a common ground where it where everyone
feels seen and and things are as as fair
as as they can be no I don't know well
here we are
you're six weeks out from you know
sharing this publicly yeah I mean you
reached out to me like you're wanting to
tell this story and to share it so I
can't help but presume that that there's
some aspect of you that wants to be you
know if not a role model like somebody
who is in this conversation you know in
service to other people who are you know
struggling quietly with what you had to
go through yeah I think I look back to
myself as a 12 year old and and you know
I wouldn't I wouldn't change how this
how everything played out from when I
found out until until this moment
sitting here with you but I do think
that a big motivation for me in telling
the story and coming on
you know this podcast and and sharing in
other in other areas is to be a voice
for for kids or adults who are
struggling with this or struggling with
any sort of identity or whatever they're
going through in that there is a
platform for you to be seen and to be
heard and how you're born and how you
feel is validated and it is legitimized
and and just you know so much of life is
just finding commonalities with people
and being able to relate and I remember
the first time I met up with someone for
the first time knowing that they were
intersex going into this meeting it was
something I'll never forget it was the
most incredible experience for the first
time getting to relate to someone in
person that has gone through the exact
same things as me so kind of taking that
and putting it on a platform that
obviously I can't meet every single
intersex person to ever exist so and not
every enter six person to ever exist
will see this story but the more that I
can share it and put light on it
hopefully the the more corners of the
world it'll reach and you don't have to
be intersex to relate to my story I
think I think everyone is going through
something internally that you know they
or something that they feel on the
inside that they don't feel like they
can share or you know talk about or or
identify with this is the stories for
them as well and whatever you're feeling
on the inside it's you know it needs to
be respected and it needs to be
addressed and you you will always have
people in your life that are that are
willing this to sit down and hear you so
what is the one thing that you you don't
want that person to hear
who you know who is dealing with this
quietly I think what I would have wanted
to hear is that the way you're born is
is perfect you're perfect just the way
you are and it can really be distilled
down into a simple process of you need a
trigger a behavior and a reward from a
brain perspective so if you see food you
eat the food and then your stomach sends
this dopamine signal to your brain that
says remember what you ate and where you
found it now this reward based learning
process is set up to help us remember
things so it actually the dopamine
firing is there to help us remember
something it helps lay down a memory and
often dopamine and modern day gets
associated with pleasure but we can type
we can put a pin in that and talk more
about that later
not really a whole lot of pleasure in
that agitated frenetic driven got to do
this yeah right and that's that's the
drive to use more when we get addicted
so basic learning process remember where
food is same thing remember we're
dangerous you know you see the
saber-toothed tiger you run away and
then you get to remember okay don't go
back there or I won't get to do that
again so that process it still it plates
the strongest learning mechanism
mechanism that's known in science all
the way evolutionarily conserved all the
way back to the sea slug so really
really well-known process yet in modern
day it's still at play but we have
availability of food 24/7 right we all
have refrigerators there you can you can
find a diner a restaurant that's open at
any time day or night you can get food
delivered anytime day or night so we
don't really need to remember where food
is anymore we just need to remember what
our phone is and we can order it yet our
brains still saying well hey you know
I'm taking up a whole lot of real estate
for this learning mechanism so let's use
it and so we start to learn to do things
like eat when were stressed or anxious
not when we're hungry you know and this
splits out hedonic versus homeostatic
hunger you know the homeostatic hunger
is like when we're actually hungry the
hedonic is based on emotions and based
on stress and things like that we
learned to take pills when we are a mo
Emily or physically in pain as compared
to learning you know to deal with it you
know social media is engineered for the
the likes and the retweets
so yeah it's it extrapolates out even to
things like that are as as a nerd is
boredom you know it doesn't have to be
this sense of disease or some kind of
emotional discomfort or or or something
that triggers an uncomfortable memory it
can be as banal as standing in line at
the grocery store yeah yeah I don't know
if you've ever pulled up to a stoplight
late at night and you look around and
everybody's crotch is glowing no it's
like suddenly thirty seconds at a red
light is intolerable
right well we only got there because
we've let ourselves get there and we can
say oh I'm not gonna do that you know
I'm gonna be a good boy in and will
power my way through this forget about
it like you said it that doesn't work so
let's get into why it doesn't like why
is it that I can't override that impulse
and through sheer force of will like
Marshall my mental and emotional powers
to prevent myself from doing that thing
that I am so lured - yeah it sounds
pretty good doesn't it you know where
these rational thinking beings I think
Descartes really sent us down a path
that's not so good you know oh I'm
thinking therefore I can think my way
through stuff it's not how our brains
were yeah you know the there's a part of
the brain the prefrontal cortex that
that's involved in in willpower it's the
weakest part of the brain from an
evolutionary perspective it's the first
that goes offline when we're stressed
when were angry when we're sad when
we're tired you know that's why we
wander into the kitchen late at night
looking for something because we're you
know we've we've learned that and so we
can say don't do that
but then we just crash harder you know
and in the morning we set that resolve
to like okay I'm really gonna do it this
time
but that's just not how our brains work
our brains don't don't work that way but
we think you know I think it's more
rationalizing you know willpower it must
be something let's study it and there
you know there's been a little bit of
this and that but it turns out
willpower if you look at the people you
know that quote-unquote have good
willpower habits there there's some
really interesting pieces there one is
they actually find things that they
enjoy doing so people you know you
people do something like eat healthy or
exercise if you ask them why they do it
the people that are really good at doing
it and you probably know this personally
it feels good as compared to oh I need
to get in shape to get a you know my
body looking this way for the brain it's
not like an intellectual exercise not at
all and that's that part makes sense but
that's not willpower and it makes sense
because that is reward based learning
we're doing something out of the reward
of doing it not because we're doing it
so that's one of the big misconceptions
around willpower is that if you look at
reward based learning it's based on the
reward it's not based on the behavior
itself so if it were the behavior we
just say stop doing this but it's
actually the reward that drives future
behavior and that's where we can start
to intervene how does it correlate with
intelligence because just speaking from
personal experience I've noticed over
the years through my adventures and
journeys in the in the recovery
community that people who are hyper
intelligent often struggle the most
because they want to intellectualize
this where truly it is an emotional
thing more than anything else and so
they struggle trying to wrap their heads
around how to do this and they can't let
go of the idea that that that solution
resides within the mind yeah well so hi
my name is Judd and I might I'm in
thinking addict
there you go if you look at the
bookshelves in my house they are way too
numerous
so speaking from personal experience and
I think this this applies is there's
this it's almost like the thinking part
of our brain is kind of like this it's
like it's like refined sugar or refined
carbohydrates it actually just gets us
stoked like oh that's interesting I'm
just gonna learn more and I'm gonna
learn more and I'm gonna figure out the
solution to this thing meanwhile day
after day after day you're perpetuate
the same behaviors unknowingly yeah I
know you're buying every self-help book
yeah so what we really need is to land
in our body because our body is really
really wise and so this is you know this
intellectual thing is like you know it's
it's that it just drives more addiction
where it's like I want to learn more as
compared to really landing on our direct
experience that says you know dude why
would you do that I'll give you an
example so with we did a study with with
people who are trying to quit smoking
and we randomized people to get
cognitive therapy or mindfulness
training where we trained them to really
just pay attention to the results of
their behavior so when they come into
the mindfulness group they don't even
know what they're getting you know and
so they come in they're like I'm here to
quit smoking and I say okay next when
you go home smoke and they're looking at
me like this experiment thing is this
this study and I say no smoke but pay
attention as you smoke and see what
happens so they pay attention to the
smell to the taste to the feeling of the
superheated smoke going into their lungs
and they come back and they're this mr.
yuck look on their face they're like oh
my god how they never noticed that
before because they realized that
smoking tastes like [ __ ] and they can
only get that wisdom from their direct
experience I had a guy who so we when
our first study we we first classes on
Monday second class was on Thursday this
guy was smoking thirty cigarettes a day
he'd been smoking that for a long time
he came back on Thursday and he said
yeah I'm down to ten cigarettes and I
said well what happened and he said well
I noticed that I would drink coffee and
the coffee was kind of bitter so I'd
smoke a cigarette to numb myself from
the taste because it's amazing how
smoking numbs your taste and so he
realized well I don't need to smoke I
could brush my teeth
and he just went through this litany of
twenty cigarettes where they were all he
was smoking all these things out of
habit where he'd you know he'd learned
through this reward based learning
process that oh if I smoke I feel better
you know or whatever no this was this is
not a good way to go so the idea being
you talk about this in your book is
diverging from what Skinner calls the
operant can
auditioning right which is behaviorism
yes traditional approach to like dealing
with these kinds of problems to a more
Buddhist perspective which you call or
is called dependent origination right
and this involves being present for the
experience and rather than getting into
judgment self judgment to just be
curious about what's happening yeah
absolutely
and it's interesting so one of the one
of the first aha moments for us in my
you know my research career was when I
was looking on studying this operant
conditioning or positive negative
reinforcement and I was thinking wait a
minute this sounds way too familiar and
I started looking into this because I've
learned you know I on a retreat or
something I'd learn this this dependent
origination piece and it was kind of you
know complex over these twelve steps and
all this stuff about birth and it sounds
like well what is this but when I looked
at it and I actually worked with a Pali
scholar to really explore this it turns
out that dependent origination explains
operant conditioning and so the Buddhist
psychologists had figured this out
twenty-five hundred years ago before
paper was even invented and so they were
describing the same process and
importantly this process depend or
generation was what reportedly the
Buddha was contemplating on the night of
his enlightenment as in hey pay
attention guys this is kind of important
so really important concept that
actually is rediscovered in modern day
and drives you know in explains a lot of
how addictive behavior is born well in
terms of the launching off kind of point
for the book you know contextually right
now we're in a culture in which you know
we've never been more starved of our
ability to be still like we're in this
crazy attention-deficit era of
unprecedented proportions I mean you
talk about the CNN effect but you know
we're in the CNN effect on steroids like
it's a sure way crazier than just news
being on television 24 hours a day and
it's become increasingly more and more
difficult
to put the phone down and spend you know
one minute with ourselves sure and we
tend to think of this as you know a
modern epidemic and I thought it was
really cool that you open the book with
this story of Seneca and you realize
like oh this isn't like this has been
going on forever like this guy had the
exact same problem that I had this
morning yes
yeah there's and actually I'd written
the book without that I started with so
I started with the Lincoln story that's
originally where the book was gonna open
there's a story about Lincoln saying
there's this city that's a key and that
the Civil War can't be won without the
key and so it's like oh that's the title
of the book stillness is the key that's
was gonna be around and I sent it really
draft of it to Robert Greene and he was
like I really like it but I feel like
you have to like rooted and where we are
right now which is amazing advice and he
was like isn't there this letter from
Seneca where he's like in Rome and he's
like describing exactly how noisy and
loud it is and sounds exactly like a
modern city and I was like yeah I think
there is let me go look for that and I
found it and I was like exactly I was
probably in a hotel room when I found it
it's noisy I got a bunch of and Seneca
just he's writing to his friend and he's
basically he's like it's so loud outside
my window that I wish I was deaf you
know and he's described staying above a
gym basically and he's like these people
are dropping weights and there's people
splashing in the pool there was a guy
getting arrested downstairs like you're
just like it it sounds it sounded like a
summer afternoon in New York City right
when you just want to blow your brains
out because it's so loud yeah and and
he's like but I'm trying to work and I
and and he describes that stoic state
that apatheia where like that equanimity
where you're you manage to tune it all
out and you kind of go into that flow
state and you do what you have to do and
that's what stillness is to me stillness
isn't like the monk who renounces all
his possessions and of course is still
because he's on a you know a ten year
meditation retreat and the beautiful you
know Buddhist monastery in the mountains
it's like oh you can get this anywhere
and in fact it's harder to get in
but that's where it's most valuable yeah
the mastery is in taking it into the
world and we are somebody like Seneca or
a fortune 500 executive or a quarterback
you're shouldering tremendous
responsibilities and pressure and
there's a lot of external stimuli that's
vying for your attention and the mastery
is in trying to figure out what's
important and what's not and and and
being you know able to focus on what is
key
actually in moving you forward on the
trajectory that that you know you're
here to do yes
yeah that's exactly right and that's why
the people who can do it either produce
this sort of stunning things that take
our breath away or get paid all the
money because like no one else can do it
it's really hard and it was refreshing
to hear Seneca like you know sort of
struggling with this grappling with it
in real time yes because we think of him
as somebody who has mastered these well
what I liked about the Seneca stories
it's not just hey this guy has some
ability to tune out the noise because
what if you're sensitive it's like also
his personal life has collapsed
everything's falling apart
everything's so if he's also going like
you're saying yeah there are all these
outside noises but often times the noise
is in your head it's you are then or
it's in your you've got some spiritual
malady that's causing and so it's that
he's able to do it on all the fronts at
the same time and clear and clear it and
get and I don't think I don't think
stillness is this I think the other
things people think stillness is maybe
that idea if Nirvana out like you get
there and then you're there I think it's
it's like can you get it for 20 minutes
mm-hmm and what can you do in the 20
minutes that you have you know what I
mean it's like it's talking about
football it's like the stillness that
New England has down being being down 28
to 3 in the Super Bowl and just
stringing together four or five drives
in 12 minutes to pull off this thing the
high maybe the high-water mark of the
entire game and then you go back to
regular life and you you dream about
getting back there sometime do you know
what I mean
you just have these moments where it all
comes together and and I think the book
and what I've been thinking a lot about
is how do you build a life how do you
build habits how to build systems how do
you build a practice that lets you get
there every once in a while because when
you do it's just magical and that's
where all the good stuff comes from well
from a very top level the book really
you know when you are trying to drive
the reader towards this understanding of
what it means to be still and the
importance of stillness it's it strikes
me as as really this journey to learn to
turn inward and and really crowd out the
externalities it's the externalities
that create the confusion and the stress
and the anxiety and you know the
competitive nature and the measuring and
all of those things that prevent us from
being clear on you know what it is you
know that is ultimately driving us I
think it's true but I think maybe that's
something that Eastern philosophy people
miss read and if they go like okay like
I gotta eliminate noises I got a
eliminate distraction I gotta live a
quieter life blah blah blah it's like
Tiger Woods had like a monk like
obsession with golf but was so broken
spiritually that it wasn't like noise in
Tiger Woods's ear that was making him
unhappy it was the voice inside of his
head you know what I mean and and so I
think you can fix it I think I'm trying
to say you got to attack it from all
angles like if you have mental
discipline but then you know you have
this deep insecurity inside you that's
you know gonna never never feel like
you're enough in a way almost your
mental discipline is your worst enemy
because it's just going to be you think
like oh I if I win a Super Bowl I will
be happy you know or dad will love me if
I become a billionaire well in addition
to to athletes and sports franchises I
mean your your writing has been embraced
by Silicon Valley like these other
subcultures that are really steeped in
in you know that that like fine edge of
performance and and generally just how
to live a more meaningful life and do it
in a you know in a grounded
teach ik and fundamentally rewarding way
I hope so yeah so stillness is the
evolution of this process yeah and I and
I say evolution very mindfully like I
think it really is in certain ways it's
synthesis of your other books and it's
also you know a very natural next
chapter and certainly your most
spiritual book yes so I'm interested in
how you arrived at the decision to
tackle this subject matter and why this
became your next book yeah I mean I
think stillness the idea of stillness
not like I'm not referring to the book
but the idea is that that concept of
stillness it struck me as like when you
remove ego stillness emerges you need
stillness to overcome these kinds of
obstacles so it was sort of it's sort of
the glue that got went unsaid in the
other books and and so I was I just kept
coming back to this idea and when you
look at really great people whether
they're athletes or generals or just
like a wise person that you met or
you're a grandfather what they all seem
to have is that you I just cuz I'm not a
still person I'm like a high-energy
person you probably hear through the
microphone I can move my arms a lot you
know I'm like that kind of person so
when I meet someone who's like oh you're
just like operating on a different plane
yeah that like unflappable yeah you know
groundedness it almost seems archaic
because it is so rare that you now meet
somebody of that kind of stature yes and
what's interesting is that basically and
this is what inspired the book is that
like basically any and all of the
ancient schools have there are talked
about that idea in their own way as the
sort of like the end goal of what we're
doing yeah it's a consistent thread that
you'll find in every philosophy and
every religion fundamentally which is
something that that you explore it's
like stoicism and Epicureanism
are supposed to be opposite philosophies
huh and yet like Stokes talked about
they and the Epicureans talk about
ataraxia yeah I wrote down all those
words and I can only pronounce a few of
them yeah as lama histo histo vote yes
Samad mom I just went through all of
them to record the audio book but I was
just in that those two it's like wait
they have these are opposite
philosophies they have the same idea in
basically very similar words you're just
like whoa how does that hat and then you
realize oh that's just what we're all
working towards everybody is trying
everyone wants to be calmer and more in
control and less like heart beating out
of their chest at the whim of their
emotions our insecurities and and and
that we need it not only at like the
personal level but also we know that's
where our best like professional work
comes from and so that I was just
fascinated with that I've never
considered you know it's really only
I've never considered from my upgrading
men or women don't do this job I mean
you can definitely look around the room
go there aren't that many women climbing
instead of me sort of being like you
know well that sucks it would be well
let's invite some more in and so that
has tended to be my mentality was
cycling well this is your whole thing
now right the inclusivity and and trying
to you know Rodney's broaden the doors
you make those doors swing wide open for
more women to get involved it's pretty
great I mean you see it now you go to a
climbing gym and there's tons of kids
and girls and everybody's climbing and
riding bikes and having fun and but yeah
at the time there weren't a lot of women
doing it and you know I didn't really
think about that rich I wasn't like oh
I'm a female climber or I'm a female
this I'm just you're just doing doing
right yeah yeah well this is the year of
free solo so you know climbing is on the
cultural roadmap in a way that never has
been before like the awareness of it
it's just exploded because of chai and
Jimmy and Alex and Tommy and that whole
community which is really cool to see
people you know at the supermarket tucky
yeah El Cap yeah and stuff like that
but I think the
the film that really paints the picture
more adeptly in terms of the culture was
for me it was Valley uprising where you
really got a sense of like what this
community is like and how it kind of
percolated up and has developed over the
years so when you know when I see that
and you're sharing with me about you
know living in your car and this dirtbag
lifestyle I mean that's what I'm
envisioning kind of like this rogue pack
of people that just kind of go where you
know the season blows them and where the
you know where the next wall is it's a
pretty special community if you think
about I mean one your your you're
connected by people in place and you go
to a place like Joshua Tree or your
cemani and even if you just stepped out
of your car and you're the average
tourist you can't help but be moved by
the nature of those places and yeah the
dirtbike climbers are now they're
cyclists doing it as well by packing
it's people who have this need to be in
that place whether you live in a city or
you get to live in you know Idaho or in
the mountains where you live of
California there is a healing factor in
nature and people know that it's just
you know people living out of their car
or committing to that lifestyle they've
just made a bigger commitment that they
need that in their life just like
somebody needs to go to church yeah well
there's something primal you know in our
human makeup and our in our base DNA
that I think yearns for that that we've
moved too far away from we have you know
I mean it's why I think if everyone
wrote a bike I went running or did
something outside for five minutes a day
our world would be a better place it's
why people put plants inside their house
you know as a grasp to have part of that
nature therapy so yeah lucky for us we
can do it you know as much as we do I
think we can all embrace more of that in
our lives i mean i think the the
discussion the conversation ends up
being around like these crazy feats
whether it's you know some of the things
that you've done or alex free soloing or
are the slack liners and you know
wingsuit people and it's about chasing
this thrill but that's not really what
it's about i think it's about what you
just mentioned which
just living more in alignment with
nature and being connected in a very
tactile way to you know this world that
supports us that's spinning around in
space I don't know too many extreme
athletes and I know a lot of all those
people that you've mentioned they're all
friends and I'm sure yeah it's a small
community it's a small dedicated
community but I don't know really anyone
I mean Alex even he accepts the risk for
what he's doing but none of us go in
with the intention of wanting to yeah
there's a sense that there are
everyone's an adrenaline junkie and I
don't think that's fair or accurate no
maybe endorphin junkie it might be a
little worried or or I mean for me I
didn't choose to go to Alaska and try to
survive sub-zero temperatures just
because I wanted to risk frostbite and
see what would happen it was that I
really wanted to experience Iditarod
Trail in Alaska and to to howl at the
moon with the wolves and to be so deep
into you know the last frontier and
wilderness but your Y is bigger than
that overall do you know your Y a little
bit yeah but you're the one hot to you I
know I am I'm working on it and and it
isn't really until I mean your TED talk
was about your Y it was and I was just
gonna say it wasn't until 46 really when
I rode the Ho Chi Minh Trail that that
you know I've been an explorer all my
life but that was the first time that I
started to explore inside instead of
outside and that that trail riding that
trail really did make me instead of
running and looking for a finish line
and and grabbing the next adventure it
it made me slow down and and stop and
look inside for a minute and that was
really hard for more than a minute right
but that was a big transition for me to
understand why I am doing this and you
know people asked all the time you know
why do you torture yourself or you know
it seems painful and awful and what are
you doing and yeah I hope in trail and
the subsequent four years that have
followed in that journey
you have helped me understand and that's
why I went back to Alaska to is because
I can finally articulate what I stand
for and what I'm doing and and the why
but it's still that kid in Downers Grove
Illinois who wanted to dig around in the
dirt in the backyard the the impetus is
the exploration but now it's a lot more
awareness of the internal exploration
instead of just the physical and and I
think also and what I get out of you
know your journey is this discovery of
how you can take these adventures and
these experiences that you've had and
and translate them tell stories around
them in a way that can be of service to
other people whether it's opening that
door for more women to get involved or
you know really to be of service to the
people of Southeast Asia you know which
we're going to get into I think it's an
amazing transition and hopefully all
humans get there you know it's part of
the aging process perhaps when we
realize that that the more you give the
more you get back and that it really
just isn't about us anymore or yourself
anymore and that has been a really
exciting revelation for me then yeah I'm
still super competitive
I was afraid when I got back from the Ho
Chi Minh Trail that the competitive
nature and spirit was gone and what am I
gonna do now and and what does this all
mean and that really is where I I spent
probably a couple years and what you
might call depression I'm trying to
evaluate well Who am I now and what does
this all stand for and and is the
athlete competitor and me gone and if
she is what's next yeah so how does that
kind of inform your your on this
interior journey now right like you know
how do you think of yourself as a as a
spiritual being like what is your
spiritual perspective on this I mean it
just seems like it couldn't be any other
way what's been really apparent to me is
the connectivity of human
and how these threads of people you've
never met in your whole life that but
you still are connected and I don't know
the terms to explain it you know but
that the village man that I met who is
the son of the father who buried my
father and you know meeting him face to
face and we'd met a lot of Lau villagers
along the way and and I didn't know that
we were pulling up to his house you know
I knew her near the place and this
village chief was gonna take me there
and I locked eyes with this guy you know
the million not a hundred law villager
who we'd met along the way I locked eyes
with this person and there was something
about him I couldn't stop staring at him
and he smiled at me and I smiled at him
and then found out later that his dad
buried my dad and and he was gonna take
me there and he even his mother was
pregnant at the time of the crash and so
his dad had told him this whole story
growing up and the village shaman had
said to the mom you know when one soul
dies another is born and you know this
soldier is is basically in your belly in
you this is part of you and so mr. air
when he's telling me this through a
translator he reaches down and shows me
and he has it's kind of a funny story he
has six toes and he pointed to his six
toe and said see this is proof that we
we're brother and sister you know we're
a part of each other and I've never met
this man he lives in a hut in the middle
of the jungle and yet we're connected
and when I went back the time again a
year later you know I've taken trips
back there now three times and I asked
him you know were you surprised to see
me and he's like no and then the last
time I went I you know I kinda asked
again I said did you know we were coming
back and he said yeah I had a dream I
saw you in a dream a month ago I knew
you're coming Wow and I believed him
these things like the connectivity of
humans is just fascinating to me and
people that have served with my dad
we've become good friends my sister and
I become closer because of it all and
there is there is a reason behind it all
and
and so yeah what are you using call it
spirituality or Konex
connectivity but it's to me reinforces
how important it is that we find
community in our lives whether it's
through your running club or your family
or through a charity or whatever it is
that humans have to make connections we
want to create spaciousness around the
subject because the way it's been
communicated has really put people off
or make them numb or make them feel bad
and so we want to communicate in such a
way that actually drew people into it
and it played out it's taught from every
grade from 4th grade 5th 6th 7th all the
way to MIT graduate school Harvard
Graduate School Stanford UC Berkeley 10
14 languages it's in the second-biggest
hotel chain New Zealand along with the
Gideon Bible in every room it just goes
on Wow and I it's telling better now
that did two and half years ago the
biggest sprint is 12th printing was the
biggest printing so far by the way this
is a book that penguin did not want to
print because your books don't sell but
the the point being is I feel like if
you create spaciousness for people to
come in and and make up their own mind
and get interested in narratives and
stories and so forth you're doing you're
going to do much better than if you
hammer them and say if you don't do
something or we don't do something we're
screwed and that may be true in a kind
of interesting way but it doesn't it's
ineffective and so I'm always trying to
think how do you create this
spaciousness so it's not a duality you
know I'm you know and and and I mean ink
use his portraits about non-duality you
know right and and so duality is really
the core dis-ease that we have you know
and when we say combating climate change
or I'm gonna fix it you know I mean or
we're gonna fight it you know it's so
crazy because it's like there's an if
somewhere I'm gonna go like this right
now
okay yeah okay this is good right this
is the atmosphere go fight it and tackle
it as you will
climates not the problem we're the
problem we're the pot right human
problem and we actually want the clients
to change we're trying to get it to
change in a different direction if it
doesn't we're screwed
so it does we needed to change the
question is we need to change what we do
and how we relate to each other and down
here in order to stabilize the climate
and that's what driver yeah well this
this stems from and you've talked about
this a lot this the sense of other other
night when we look at the at the climate
or our environment as something that's
other or or other individuals and what
they're doing as other as opposed to
embracing the you know unifying holistic
nature you know of oneness that we all
are that's what we need to step into and
to really to really like crock the
solution here we all grew up with a
conditioned mind that basically steals
our joy if we let it yeah
and that conditioned mind it first of
all it's like we're an individual uh-huh
well so here's here's here's a question
for you
as a man of science and I'm and and
somebody who worked very hard with their
team to to create this here we should
show it for those who haven't seen it
this this beautiful book that's so
inviting that you can read if you're in
fourth grade or you're a PhD student
it's all very organized and digestible
and it's about the data and the math how
do you square being this man of science
with your you know for Buddhist leanings
and your spiritual perspective on how we
solve these problems well I'm not a man
of science a man of science appreciation
I'm a gentleman okay yeah
I don't think I read it done well in
science at all and the Buddhist
perspective is really one of really
obviously used terms mindfulness and you
know awareness I'm a really piss-poor
Buddhist so I just want to put that out
there I know some that are fantastic and
I only you know bow to them every
television jack Kornfield is a friend I
just think he's an incredible teacher
and but the but the the the the the
basic teachings are about practice about
what to become if you understand the
identity and if you confused about
identity I am
fill in the blank you're confused hmm
basically and then from that confusion
arises actions that are inappropriate or
unskillful or harmful or unkind and
generosity arises from that
transcendence kindness arises from that
compassion arises from that and I feel
like this this situation we're in the
most gnarly super wicked problem
humanity has ever described may ever
face if there's we still here is
actually a blessing and not a curse it's
I mean you can look at it like it's
happening to me and say I'm the victim
and be pissed off and then you live your
life in that mind that's the mind you
living that's the world you're living in
and that's kind of a hell realm and if
we look at it from the point of view
it's feedback and from the atmosphere
but actually from the whole of the earth
because you can't really separate that
miss fear from plants and forests and
water if you're looking for that way
then it's a gift it's feedback and you
take a hundred percent responsibility
you don't ask other people to do it you
take a higher percent responsible for
your actions who you are and then you
begin to amount
to innovate you know you do what incuse
doing you do you know spoken word or
whatever you do things that make sense
to you that help you connect more to
this beautiful extraordinary miracle
they call the living room and that's the
gift of climate change it's a gift this
transformation of self and of the world
and the solutions are transformative and
those are just some of them you know
there's a lot more and so we can either
accept the offering and the gift or we
can go into self-pity yeah yeah I mean I
think you don't as I as I try that on
this idea that global warming global
climate change is happening for us as
opposed to to us and how does that feel
there is an empowerment I think with
that this sense of possibility that that
there are things that I can do you can
do we can do collectively and then I
scroll through my Twitter feed and I see
what's happening at the highest levels
of government and what's happening with
well-funded lobbyists on K Street and
the farm bill and the subsidies and the
lack of regulation and oversight and the
stripping away of protections and all
the like and all of that goes out the
window
yeah so how do you navigate that that
minefield of what's happening in
government the things that actually you
don't you can't control you don't have
to say yeah well I mean I read the same
RSS feeds and stuff that you do every
morning I don't meet him at night and
yeah
I think first of all I mean javis has a
famous line you know fear is the shabby
room in the house you deserve better
conditions and and so fear is not a
place to live in it doesn't work
and so to me it's about curiosity which
is like huh look what they did look what
he said look what he tweeted oh my gosh
it's like really and then when i when i
read the presidential tweets ago he's
talking about himself again he's talking
about himself he said you know
disgusting bad you know
corrupt you know yeah that's true I mean
I mean I said you that's he knows
himself really well yeah he really does
you know and so I say you know and and
so when I see the ignorance or the
inability to connect again it's going to
connect you know I become curious as to
what is the solution to that that was
what is the communication what is it
this going with it what will it take
actually and one of the things about
this week and the week prior not just
the things that Greta - berg side which
was so extraordinary but I mean this
science as it was coming out is that the
sense of urgency is really growing
exponentially which is quite interesting
and I feel like and I mean that
basically and people say well were not
doing enough and we're losing and it's
happening too fast and all that sort of
stuff
but I think if you actually look at the
climate movement and the rate of growth
it's growing faster than the inertial
problem of even killing the earth and we
are at that stage where I think more and
more people are going to realize that
degeneration or liquidation of the earth
actually we're coming to a dead end on
that one and so I feel like the urgency
is going to change very rapidly and
those who think they're ineffective and
I mean Zack Bush and I are on a stage
together a few weeks ago and what I
came out I said were rehearsing the
future knows we're rehearsing an
awareness and understanding and practice
that as people wake up they will move to
and look to in practice and an act and
it doesn't go the other way now is there
enough time unanswerable question will
we make it unanswerable question those
questions are irrelevant what's relevant
is our hearts and who we are and what we
do and are we actually fully engaged I
mean there's no difference between a
climate denier and somebody who's
literate and climate and doesn't do
anything they both don't do anything so
what's the difference
[Music]